at last my final four and now i'm the  perfect qb really a forty-three on the  bottom the 2007 team though  i can't let you get that seventh ring  tom  ow my ribs oh i'll give you a few weeks  watch out all pretty swimmers are number  one options well know for all exactly  no stop punching chauncey garner johnson  now kneel before the goal i'll never  kneel  i mean for him look i respect you guys  so much  i might be able to get a completion  let's check in around the lead  oh you hate to see them leading with  their head we can actually [ __ ] win  this thing  i choose you jared goff i already told  you nerds i'm not doing this anime stuff  but i don't  have the arm strength every dumb little  completion  oh no brady's ego is getting bigger one  of us has got to go  is this the afterlife come come talk on  tv like one day a week forever  [Music]  who's that rams player  it's aaron donald aaron donald